welcome back to CBS this morning here's
the first look at aerial footage of the
massive Greenland ice sheet provided by
NASA it's part of a decade-long effort
to track the potentially dangerous ice
melt data released in March shows that
melting has left to hold the size of
Texas I'm from Texas that's big in the
Greenland sheet that's critical because
Greenland and Antarctica together
contained 99% of the world's freshwater
ice now in just a few minutes we'll show
you why that could pose a worldwide
danger but first our earth manners
coverage turns to the fragile Rio Grande
one of the country's longest and most
iconic rivers for nearly 2,000 miles the
river winds its way from the Rockies
down to the Gulf of Mexico more than 6
million people in three states rely on
it for drinking water and irrigation but
climate change is threatening that vital
flow we sent Michelle Miller on a 300
mile journey along the Rio Grande she
joins us now from las Cruces New Mexico
Michelle good morning good morning by
this time of year water should be
flowing apart along this part of the Rio
Grande in fact exactly where I am
standing now but farmers who rely on it
are gonna have to wait at least another
month it's a side effect of a drought
that is cycled on for the last 17 years
and scientists are predicting it will be
even hotter and drier in the future that
means folks who rely on this River will
have to adapt to what could be their new
normal for more than a hundred and
thirty years this river gauge in
northern New Mexico has tracked the
pulse of the Rio Grande
it's the oldest continuously operated
gauge in the United States operated by
the US Geological Survey when we visited
the Rio Grande was beating along on the
bottom we have a trap door that goes
into the stilling was.but mark gun a
hydrologist with the USGS told us last
July its flow nearly flatlined
since 1889 last year was the lowest
discharge in the history of this gauge
how low did it get it was so low that we
actually had to dig out this this whole
entire area and dig a channel into the
river to be able to get water to go
to the gauge so it basically made your
your your machine here malfunction
the Colorado snowpack that melts into
the Rio Grande is declining 25% in the
last 50 years and climatology professor
David gutzler says climate change is
threatening to dry it up I foresee dry
spells getting dryer droughts getting
more intense
and water resources being put under more
pressure with that in mind cities
downstream have been preparing
Albuquerque's Water Authority has spent
six million dollars incentivizing desert
friendly landscaping the city even sends
every fourth-grade class to the river
for a lesson in water conservation
that's right we followed the Rio Grande
a hundred and fifty miles south to where
it pulls into the Elephant Butte
reservoir New Mexico's largest the
shrinking reservoir can be seen from
space
but up close you can see the back tub
ring left by higher water levels 25
years ago we're sort of a microcosm of a
lot of river systems in the world so
you're saying that the Rio Grande is the
canary in the coalmine
sure think of it that way as things warm
up for a given level of precipitation
you get less water into your river and
into your reservoirs that means less of
it can be released to the 90,000 acres
of farmland on the other side of this
dam it is now April and we have not
released any water from storage we
should have been running for a month and
a half by now a month and a half yeah
until water is released in June parts of
the Rio Grande will look like this dusty
and dry like the desert around it and
the canals that deliver water to farms
like Dixie Ranch will remain empty so
what happens upstream directly
correlates with what you see here
absolutely lots of snow will have years
of lots of water
Greg DA VA has prepared as 310 acres of
pecan trees for either scenario he's
added more ground water wells for
irrigation during drought so this is a
volumetric soil moisture probe and
brought techni
to the century-old farm to ensure that
every drop counts so we've developed a
computer program for our farm and when I
irrigate the tree it can then predict
when it'll need to be irrigated again da
VA doesn't deny the climate is changing
he's just not ready to panic droughts
come and go
you don't sound worried the worry would
be that there's a future that I can't
plan for and I worry that it's coming I
believe that we can plan that we can
adapt and that we can adjust to whatever
conditions come everyone's hoping that
this year is above average snowpack will
offer some relief but it won't mean that
the drought is over in fact one study is
predicting that by the turn of the next
century that if everything stays the
same this part of the rio grande water
levels will drop by 50% Gayle oh boy we
don't want to think about that thank you
very much Michelle